this is the worst driving ever
Catherine you have to try not to laugh
okay okay try not to laugh
good morning today is our last day in
Magic Kingdom
everyone's excited yeah yeah let's go
Magic Kingdom last day make the magic
happen have a magical day
[Music]
you ready for the last day Catherine
yeah yeah what do you what are you most
looking forward to
nothing you don't know
[Music]
are you guys ready for the last day yeah
last day of magic yeah
let's go
all right the first time we wanted to go
to the backlight years but they are
closed the first ride and it's closed
yeah it's okay I'm gonna find something
else we're gonna plan something else
we're gonna go to The Little Mermaid the
boys are very excited for The Little
Mermaid
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
was it fun candy yeah exciting yeah
enjoyed yeah all right let's go next one
all right they are going to the speedway
bumper car I am gonna sit up because I
don't like to smell the gasoline
guys are going by themselves
and I'm the passenger with her
you're telling me the way are you gonna
be a good driver yeah you sure you
promise
seat belts
[Music]
this is the worst driving ever
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
light years Space Ranger
it's Extravaganza okay let's go
all right this is me and Hayden
and then this is Catherine what about
Uncle Evan I got second place if Hayden
didn't spin you so much you probably
would have won that yeah oh I told him
stop spinning he's like can't spend it I
said stop we Jeffrey and I were getting
on ours we get on the ramp there's a kid
in front of us Jeffrey's like takes him
out of the way no I didn't no I didn't
separates him from the library lion so
that was his karma next one we're going
to Monsters Inc it's gonna laugh yeah
together you have to try not to laugh
okay okay try not to laugh
it opens at 10 o'clock so we're going to
People Mover instead yes
[Music]
all right monster Inc is open now we
have to hustle
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
next one is um Space Mountain let's go
all right uh the Space Mountain was fun
the boys and I enjoyed it we were
expecting to go backwards but there was
no backwards so it was nice because I
was a little nauseous going in so good
for me next one next up we're gonna have
some lunch and then uh keep going
[Music]
lunch is done I was gonna say dinner
stand but no it's lunch is done
Barnstormer
next thing let's go
foreign
Barnstormers let's go lightning Lane I
can't believe even my nephew is making
fun of my height Evan well I think you
believe it he's making fun of my height
well you always
special
she's just extra special she's Nina have
a safe flight Evan
[Music]
it's done
I took my phone out just to film the
last two seconds as we landed well it's
better than nothing next one we're going
to the Carousel for the nine years old
[Music]
all right we're getting a dessert
dessert drink
[Music]
cheers
Step It Up Zippity Doo sip it up was it
good Evan
whoa strong
yeah is it good Jeffrey oh that's
[Music]
let's go
last rice time to go to the Small World
ride
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
always enjoyed this one Nina wanted me
to look up the lyrics to the songs so
she could sing along and ride because I
don't know I don't know the lyrics at
all even when you fake your way through
it you sound amazing
because I sound amazing anyways all
right time to go home bye Magic Kingdom
bye Disney thank you for having us
all right so what happened last night uh
we basically came home uh chill like
always and then watched two episodes of
The Stranger Things
and then we went to sleep and today is
the day that we go home we pack
everything and
um
Evan's gonna load the car no load the
suitcase to the car
and we're gonna head to the airport
[Music]
oh my God finally we got off the plane
they hold us up there for like 20
minutes at least yeah first they let
people the connection people off first
and they hold us up there for like 20
minutes now we finally get to go home
finally I'm tired
so it has been a chaos we finally
finally got out of the airport now
waiting for our Uber and to go home
I like to relax
[Music]
so we are now home I hope you enjoyed
the trip and the journey and if you want
to see why we went to Paris on day one
and what that Journey looked like from
the start there's a video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you